denkwürdiger Tag heute Herr Kuhle
deshalb die erste Frage an Sie wie
überrascht sind sie das dann heute doch
noch in Sachen Gag Gebäude Energiegesetz
weiß er auch aufgestiegen ist ich bin
nicht überrascht es haben ja die
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
die Fraktionsvorsitzenden und am Ende
auch Christian Lindner Olaf Scholz und
Robert habe über dieses Thema verhandelt
und so ist das eben drei
unterschiedliche Parteien ringen
miteinander und jetzt hat man einen
Entwurf mit dem man in die erste Lesung
gehen kann damit nur noch Veränderungen
geben da gibt's noch Diskussionen aber
die Menschen können sich sicher sein das
Gesetz von Robert Habeck wird so nicht
kommen wie es ursprünglich wurde das
Betonen ja weil das der Punkt
beobachtet auf gar keinen Fall so kommen
es hat nichts mit der Person zu tun
Inhalt zu tun dass die Menschen heute
schon keinen Termin bekommen beim
Schornsteinfeger beim Energieberater bei
den Leuten die man mal fragen kann was
ist denn jetzt eigentlich mit meiner
Haltung da ist eine riesiges Maß an
Unzufriedenheit
nicht erschließen können deswegen ist es
gut dass ich daran was verändert hat
weil sie das so betonen dass dieses böse
habeck-gesetz jetzt nicht kommt sie
haben mehr als FDP zweimal diesem Gesetz
zugestimmt zweimal in der
Bundesregierung ja ja aber ich bin ja
parlamentarierer
absolut und wir entscheiden aber im
Bundestag ja selber was wir aufsetzen
und was nicht der Bundestag ist ja nicht
die abnickvorrichtung für die Regierung
das heißt sie haben als
fdp-parlamentarier mit ihrer FDP
Regierung nichts zu tun wir haben ganz
viel mit denen zu tun unsere Minister
sitzen sogar in der Fraktion dabei ja
das sind 92 Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
sind alle vom Volk gewählt und die soll
dieses Gesetz am Ende beschließen und
dann kann man nicht einfach sagen passt
mal auf hier ist das Gesetz das bringen
wir jetzt mal Richtung Deutschen
Bundestag sondern muss was geändert
werden klargestellt erst kommt die
kommunale Wärmung dann kommt das Gebäude
Energiegesetz wir haben klargestellt es
kann auch auf Wasserstoff gesetzt werden
das kann auch auf Gasheizung gesetzt
werden Heizen mit Holz haben wir
sichergestellt also es ist schon was
anderes
auch ihre FDP Kollege den Kollegen mit
beschlossen haben oder besprochen Leben
im Kabinett war Murks meine Gesetzgeber
ist der deutsche
Möglichkeiten wie das da landen kann das
kann die Regierung machen das können wir
selber machen oder beim Bundesrat und es
gibt eine Vorlage von Robert Harbeck die
sagt wir wollen Klimaschutz im Gebäude
Sektor und da hat der Mann recht denn
wir brauchen Klimaschutz im Gebäude
Sektor und dann gibt es eine
Diskussionsgrundlage aus der Regierung
die landet im Parlament und das
Parlament sagt moment mal das geht in
eine Richtung muss ich so viele Menschen
Sorgen machen da müssen wir vorher
gesehen
der christian hat doch an den
Fraktionssitzung teilgenommen und hat
sozusagen
Notiz bei der Zustimmung gesagt passt
mal auf liebe Leute wird sich noch was
verändern müssen und zwar beispielsweise
das Thema kommunale wärmeplanung muss
voran Heizen mit Holz die ganzen
Geschichten
Protokoll weil sie gerade Protokoll
Notizen sagen
der diesen Gesetz vorher schon zweimal
sein Segen gegeben hat aber dann
brauchen wir kein Bundestag mehr wenn
einfach die Regierung die Gesetze
beschließen aber sie stellen das ja
jetzt so als ganz normalen Prozess
sozusagen da was dein vergangenen
Monaten passiert ist das war's ja nun
nicht also ich meine der ganze
Entstehungsprozess das war würde ich
sagen eine reine
vertrauensvernichtungsmaschine innerhalb
der Ampelkoalition was total
Vernichtungsmaschine würde ich sagen ja
weil sozusagen sowohl was die drei
ampelkoalitionspartner untereinander
angeht als auch was den Blick auf die
Koalition angeht an was ist da passiert
also schon wie der Gesetzentwurf
öffentlich wurde ja da war der
vertrauensraum konnte ja nicht gesichert
werden offensichtlich er ist mehr oder
weniger zufällig an unfertiger
Gesetzentwurf an die Medien gelangt was
dann passiert ist war auch ihre Partei
hat eine Kampagne innerhalb der eigenen
Koalition gegen dieses Gesetz gemacht ja
man kann das alles machen aber man muss
sich dann natürlich auch nicht wundern
wenn dann eine Kultur sozusagen entsteht
von der am Ende nur eine Partei
profitiert nämlich die AFD und nicht die
FDP
der der Tweet von ihnen in dem
Zusammenhang mit diesem Blick der hier
würden sie das noch mal so schreiben ja
auf jeden Fall das passiert ständig also
nicht ärgert das wahnsinnig das also sie
sagen es kann durchaus sein dass das
eigene Leute arbeiten tausende Leute im
Wirtschaftsministerium natürlich kann
das von denen einer rausgegeben haben
die sogenannte früh Koordinaten ja das
sind ja nicht tausende Leute sondern das
ist eine Handvoll Leute vielleicht ein
Dutzend Leute ja nur die Beteiligten
Minister das wenige Leute im Kanzleramt
also das eine überschaubare Runde aus
der das Gesetz dann durchgestochen wurde
das ist ja deswegen auch so aufgeregt
ich könnte ja selbst wenn könnte sonst
noch gewesen sein
irgendwie wird das seinen Weg natürlich
nach außen noch gefunden haben in den
parlamentarischen Raum oder so es gibt
ja dann vertraute den man das Gesetz
vielleicht mal so zeigt oder so ja aber
trotzdem ist das was anderes als wenn es
dazu ist ja die frühkoordination
überhaupt erst eingesetzt worden dass
man einen Vertrauen hat wo nur wenige
Personen sozusagen sich drüber wollen
können über mit solchen entsetzte
Gesetzentwurf eigentlich ist dieser Raum
ja jetzt komplett zerstört das kann ich
nicht bestätigen wir machen jeden Tag
hunderte frühkoordinierungsprozesse über
verschiedene Formen in der Ampel also es
ist in diesem Gebäude Energiegesetz ganz
viel passiert was bei ganz vielen
anderen Gesetzgebungsvorhaben normal ist
es wird eine aufsetzung
abgesetzt wie gesagt wir können jetzt
über das Gesetz nicht sprechen es wird
noch mal von der Fraktion Tagesordnung
runtergenommen es wird noch mal hoch
eskaliert zu den fraktionsvorsitzen also
Dinge die bei jedem anderen Gesetz auch
vorkommen können sind bei einem Thema
jetzt besonders heißt diskutiert worden
und ich glaube das hängt damit zusammen
dass das Thema Klimaschutz betrifft was
eine zentrale Zukunft Herausforderung
ist und einen Bereich in dem viele
Menschen wirklich Angst um seine
Portemonnaie und ums eigene Haus um die
eigene Wohnung haben und das ist das
Problem ich bin sehr dafür dass wir über
politische Kulturen lassen
und jede Form von von Auseinandersetzung
in der Koalition als Zerstörungen
Atombombe für dieses Land bezeichnet der
er spricht von der Erziehungsdiktatur
und so weiter ich meine das ist doch ein
wording was sagen was was doch keiner
vernünftigen politischen Kultur
entspricht haben Sie mal gesehen was die
Grünen über Volker Wissing so sagen ich
will jetzt nicht Gleiches mit Gleichem
vergelten alles gut ja ich finde wir
müssen uns alle an die eigene Nase
fassen und alle mal alle auch die FDP
grüne SPD immer überlegen ist die Art
und Weise wie wir über den politischen
Gegner sprechen eigentlich noch in der
Sache und Argument oder ist das
vielleicht zerstörerisch für die
politische Kultur da gebe ich Ihnen
Recht aber ähm das jetzt nur die FDP bei
einem Thema was uns besonders wichtig
ist nämlich das Leute die irgendwie eine
Lebens Entscheidung für eine bestimmte
Heizung Treffen nicht in die Röhre
gucken dass wir uns da irgendwie
Versöhnlichkeit hätten an der
politischen Kultur kann okay wir reden
gleich noch mal drüber Frau ohne Bild
schon die ganze Zeit naja Vertrauens
Vernichtungsmaschine
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
wenn ich sage was macht das wohl in den
Köpfen von Menschen also bei
hypothetisch ein bisschen spekuliert was
wir da auch aus der Psychologie und der
Neurowissenschaften Wissen Vertrauen ist
ja erstmal was total positives haben wir
glaube ich oder sind wir uns hier
hoffentlich alle einig ja
Vernichtungsmaschine also gerade wenn
wir eine in einer Zeit leben in der sehr
viel
Kriegsberichterstattung auch in diesem
Land natürlich zurecht passiert sind
natürlich Bilder im Kopf die irgendwie
sehr sehr weit weg aus meiner Sicht
jetzt was von Heizung
zeigen sollten bzw Heizung und
vernichtungsmaschinen ja bzw der
politische Prozess der daran wir können
auch geknüpft ist was macht das jetzt in
den Köpfen von Menschen na ja es wird
eine Assoziation also eine Verbindung
geknüpft zwischen zwei Themen die
eigentlich überhaupt nichts miteinander
zu tun haben und da Stichwort hatten wir
gerade auch das haben sie selbst gesagt
es geht vor allem eins und das ist Angst
richtig und Angst war schon immer
Volksmund hat ja manchmal recht ne war
schon immer schlechter Berater genau und
ich füge dem ganzen ganz gerne immer
noch die uns Sicherheit hinzu also Angst
und Unsicherheit sind zusammen in
Kombination richtig schlechte Berater
und das was wir jetzt in den letzten
Monaten vor allem ja erlebt haben war
eine massive Unsicherheit hier hin und
her und so weiter und dann kommen die
Liveticker dazu die machen das nicht
unbedingt besser sondern eher schlechter
warum sind die schlechte Berater naja
sie haben es eben schon kurz gesagt sie
machen uns ich würde nicht sagen doof
sondern dümmer also
genau ich will jetzt nicht über Wörter
streiten aber sie sinken tatsächlich
unseren IQ also wenn Menschen und ganz
explizit
davor also wenn wir Stichwort
Medienberichterstattung wenn wir
negative Nachrichten sehen also z.B in
Form von Videos das ist eine Studie die
ja durchgeführt wurde auch entsprechend
publiziert ist und dann bestimmte
kognitive Aufgaben also zum Beispiel
Intelligenztest lösen müssen dann
schneiden wir schlechter ab und das
ganze dann eben entsprechend
wissenschaftlich methodisch gut
kontrolliert als wenn wir nicht in Angst
versetzt sind so und wenn wir uns jetzt
überlegen wie treffen Menschen
Entscheidungen wenn sie unter Angst sind
dass sie auf der einen Seite dümmer sind
das ist der eine Bereich auf der anderen
Seite nicht mehr in der Lage sind auf
ihr Gedächtnis zurückzugreifen also das
was sie in der Vergangenheit dazu
gebracht hat gute überlegte
Entscheidungen zu treffen ich sage immer
so ein bisschen wie so eine Sackgasse im
Hirn diese Regionen blockiert sind naja
dann führt das zu Entscheidungen die vor
allem eins sind nämlich kurzfristig
orientiert und ich spreche jetzt hier
gar nicht vom politischen Prozess
sondern der politische Prozess verknüpft
mit der Medienberichterstattung kreiert
das in den Köpfen der Menschen das heißt
die treffen dann Entscheidungen also
natürlich sind Politikerinnen und
Journalistin auch Menschen aber wenn wir
jetzt mal so die verschiedenen
Berufsgruppen anschauen ja die Menschen
nehmen nicht in diesen Bereichen
arbeiten kriegen diesen Prozess mit
kriegen mit so wird darüber geschrieben
und treffen dann Angst getriebene
Entscheidung und die sind immer immer
kurzfristig und das was wir gerade unter
Stichwort ist ja auch schon gefallen
beim Thema Klima brauchen sind
langfristige Entscheidung dafür müssen
wir aus diesem angstmodus rauskommen und
vor allem aus diesem Kampfmodus es wurde
auch ja gerade schon ein bisschen
angesprochen politische Gegner
Kulturkampf ja coole hat es selber so
genannt Kulturkampf und der Blick geht
jetzt zu Caro Masala wir reden gleich
über die Ukraine aber sie sind ja ein
sehr politischer Mensch mit ihnen kann
man über sehr viele Themen sehr gut
sprechen deswegen an dem Punkt nochmal
die Frage diese Wut die genau bei diesem
Thema herrscht das geht doch alles
mittlerweile weit über normalen
konstruktiven politischen Streit hinaus
gut zu besichtigen am Wochenende in
Erding zum Beispiel ja wir haben sie das
wahrgenommen also wir befinden uns in
ganz ganz vielen Themen in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland in so einer
Art ähm vor trumpismus also wo nicht
mehr über Sachen wo nicht mehr über die
Sache geredet wird sondern die Sache
skandalisiert wird was in Erding
passiert ist hat glaube ich noch meine
zusätzliche Dimension weil da ein
stellvertretender Minister Präsidenten
eines deutschen Bundeslandes also Hubert
eiwanger sich vor eine aufgeheizte Menge
stellt die vorher Markus Söder den
Ministerpräsidenten ausgebucht hat die
Menge ganz ruhig ist und er diese Menge
dazu auffordert dass es jetzt Zeit sei
sich die Demokratie wieder zurück wir
hören einmal damit wir wissen worüber
wir sprechen alle wir haben einmal kurz
rein ein paar Impressionen von diesem
Wochenende erst glaube ich Markus Söder
dann Huber
gerade die Grünen und das kann man sagen
treiben die Dinge so weit mit
brachialkur voran und zwar nur mit
Ideologie ohne Pragmatismus ohne
Vernunft und es sind das klare Signal
diese Politik der Grünen darf nicht die
Mehrheit in Deutschland werden meine
sehr verehrten Damen und wir wollen
nicht dass unser Land den ganzen Tag von
einigen wenigen grünen funktionieren
umgezogen wird meine sehr verdammten mit
dieser Ideologie
[Applaus]
wo endlich die schweigen die große
Mehrheit dieses Landes sich die
Demokratie wieder zurückholen muss
[Applaus]
den in Berlin sagen ihr habt ja wohl den
Arsch offen da oben meine okay das kann
das kann man machen
genau
die große schweigende Mehrheit also
erstmal zu unterstellen da gibt es eine
große schweigende Mehrheit die von einer
also demzufolge dann kleinen sehr lauten
Minderheit unterdrückt wird und von dem
müssen wir uns jetzt die Demokratie
zurückholen sagt jemand der selber
demokratisch gewählt worden genau und
damit folgendes macht delegitimiert eine
demokratisch gewählte Regierung und mein
Punkt ist so sie können die Ampel
grotten schlecht finden sie können
fordern das Scholz zurückdrücken muss
habe zurücktreten müssen sie können das
Gesetz grotten schlecht finden das ist
alles völlig legitim sie können noch
Neuwahlen rufen das ist alles völlig
legitim aber sie legt die legitimieren
also ein demokratisch gewählter
Politiker nicht die Bundesregierung die
demokratisch gewählt worden ist das
suggeriert ja dass wir uns ja in einer
Diktatur befinden und das ist letzten
Endes meine die AFD hatte mal den Slogan
wir holen uns unser Land zurück das ist
genau in die gleiche schlagrechnung das
ist Trump am 6 Januar der die Masse die
Wahlen zurück wir holen uns die Wahlen
zurück das ist ein schon meines
Erachtens für jemanden der
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
eines nicht unwichtigen deutschen
Bundeslandes ist eine neue Qualität der
politischen Demagogie
vielleicht hören wir einfach noch mal
weiter kurz zu weil es ein wirklich
Bemerkenswertes Wochenende war Martin
Hagen sie
FDP-Chef in Bayern wir hören mal kurz
rein gleiche Veranstaltung
Ideologie
und ich kann euch heute eines
versprechen
und euch meine Worte und lässt mich an
meinen Worten meine FDP wird dem Entwurf
in dieser Verfassung im Bundestag nicht
zustimmen
der coole wie finden Sie diesen Sound
ich finde es absolut richtig dass wenn
11.000 Menschen da stehen und
demonstrieren dass man da hingeht und
mit denen redet und ich weiß nicht
welche Stelle sie rausgeschnitten haben
es war ja ein Schnitt zwischendurch aber
es gibt die Stelle wo Martin Hagen sagt
wer den Menschen verspricht es könne
alles so bleiben wie es ist der handelt
verantwortungslos seit er in dieser Rede
auch gesagt und das finde ich ist der
entscheidende Unterschied zwischen einem
Hubert eiwanger und das muss ich auch
sagen ein Markus Söder und einem Martin
Hagen weil weder Söder noch äh Hagen
haben in ihren Reden in Erding den
Eindruck erweckt wir würden in einer
Diktatur leben das finde ich absolut
daneben was einfacher gemacht hat und
ich finde das trägt zum Verlust an
politischer Kultur in Deutschland bei
wenn man sich auf so eine auf so eine
Veranstaltung hinstellt als Politiker
und da sein Mann steht und sagt wir
werden dem so nicht zustimmen und ihr
könnt mich an meinen Worten messen dann
finde ich das absolut in Ordnung richtig
was Martin Hagen gemacht hat Ideologie
ist ein Begriff aus dem politischen
Meinungskampf den gibt's halt den
benutzt man halt
was heißt der benutzt man also
entschuldigung aber wir haben eine
Situation also wir haben eine eine Lage
in der bestimmten politische Akteure
versuchen den Eindruck zu erwecken dass
alle Parteien im Deutschen Bundestag
gleich sind alle haben alle stecken alle
unter einer Decke wie Altparteien wollen
sowieso alles gleich wir wollen das
schlechteste vor unserer Medien auch
noch dazu genau die werden damit rein
gerührt die Wissenschaft die Justiz also
wir haben einen Vertrauensverlust in die
Institution der liberalen Demokratie und
das wird befördert von Extremisten dass
das Problem und in dieser Lage machen
wir ein Gesetz als Bundesregierung als
Parlament Mehrheit mit dem wir das Thema
Klimaschutz im Gebäude Sektor
voranbringen wollen dann ist es doch gut
dass Menschen erkennen können dass die
Grünen die FDP und die SPD
unterschiedliche Parteien sind und ja
der ursprüngliche Entwurf aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium sag jetzt
bewusst nicht von Robert habe weg
sondern aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium findet
nicht sie Zustimmung der FDP und das
kann man auch vor 11000 Menschen und
Erding sagen
Diktatur ja
zählt Rede die muss auch künftig
sagen alle das Gleiche und das kann auch
nicht sein sie sind
ein exzellenter Jurist Herr Kohle sie
widersprechen sich jetzt hier wirklich
in zwei Sätzen also sie sagen da gibt es
diese böse Vermutung die stecken alle
unter der Decke ich teile genau
ist da gibt es diese böse grüne
Ideologie und die stecken alle die
Medien die Grünen und der Rest der
Regierung die stecken alle unter einer
Decke und die in Berlin sowieso
Ideologie
übernimmt genau dieses wording unser
heizungsideologie das ist hier von Chef
das ist der Heiz Hammer ist an der
Atombombe für unser Land wie finden sie
sowas finde ich daneben ist nicht mein
Bruder den würde ich so nicht benutzen
haben gesagt wir sind Austausch
miteinander
wir sehen uns jede Woche in der Fraktion
miteinander haben
92 Abgeordnete aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft gewählt vom Volk die Reden
unterschiedlich Schäffler redet so
kubiki redet so coole redet so redet so
es ist normal ja wir sind
unterschiedliche Menschen die sind nicht
alle gleich
es ist gut dass wir unterschiedliche
Typen in der FDP ist es gut redet es ist
gut dass Martin Hagen da hingegangen ist
und er gesagt hat ist das gut aber
gegangen
also ist es gut dass wir jetzt ein
Ergebnis haben mit denen Deutschen
Bundestag eine krasse Übertreibung im
politischen Meinungskampf die absolut
Geschmackssache ist und diesmal werden
genau den Leuten vor denen sie gerade so
eindringlich gewarnt haben nein das will
ich nicht sagen genau ja aber wenn sie
sich mal mit Frank Schäffler über
Klimaschutz unterhalten dann werden Sie
merken dass Sie sich ganz normal mit dem
übertragen das Klimaschutz unterhalten
können gerade
unterstellen das würden alle unter einer
Decke stecken oder sonstwas hinter den
Kulissen sagt er ja wir haben da ein
Problem und wir sollten das auch machen
ja vor also vorne rum sagen die Leute
Christian Lindner ist der Leibhaftige
und hinter den Kulissen setzen sich mit
ihm zusammen und von ihm das ist ganz
normal das passiert jeden Tag wir haben
noch die Vordergrund Diskussionen die
finden statt
Latein unterschiedlich
und gibt der bild-zeitungen Interview
der immer sagt der heizhammer ist an der
Atombombe für unser Land das ist eine
krasse Überschrift eine krasse
Übertreibung
es ist eine krasse Übertreibung von
deiner die ich so nicht verwenden würde
ja ich finde das sozusagen nicht meine
Sprache braucht man so ein trotzdem
gucken was passiert aber jetzt
unterstellen sie das wäre gesteuert
vielleicht ist der Chef einfach ein
selbstbewusster Abgeordneter die am Ende
entscheiden muss stimme ich dafür oder
Stimme mich dagegen mir geht's darum wie
man Leute verunsichert mir geht's darum
ist fand ich ja sehr interessant sie
sagten gerade hinter den Kulissen können
Sie mit dem ganz normal reden klar
Leute die zusammen in der Fraktion
sitzen normal miteinander reden nein
aber überraschend ist dass er
offensichtlich dann solche Wörter nicht
benutzt das heißt in Wahrheit
offenkundig das ja gar nicht denkt
ich glaube schon dass wir uns einig
waren franchefler und ich dass das
Gesetz so wie es aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium gekommen ist
nicht zustimmungsfähig gewesen
und er sagt halt jetzt haben wir erst
eine Atombombe für unser Land
unterschiedliche Typen benutzen
unterschiedliche formulieren
genau
der Unterschied also ich finde die
Argument ist gut das Differenzen auch
innerhalb einer Koalition sichtbar
werden um bestimmten Sichtweisen
irgendwie was entgegenhalten zu können
aber das ist finde ich eine andere
Nummer wenn man sich da auf eine Bühne
stellt und Restaurants verstärkt der
finde ich ist das äußerst problematisch
ich bin trotzdem bei der heizöltologie
von Herrn Hagen in Bayern
also man darf nicht sagen ich bin
grundsätzlich überhaupt nicht dagegen
mit diesem Leuten zu sprechen und sich
auf die Bühne zu stellen aber ich glaube
es kommt da sehr aufs wording und so
weiter an ja ob man ob man da bestimmte
problematische und die muss noch
verstärkt oder sie eben eindämmt und das
ich glaube das ist der Punkt ich glaube
trotzdem nicht völlig militärisch
sozusagen was diese Veranstaltung angeht
in Erding weil sie war ja auch so ein
bisschen lächerlich wenn ich das mal
sagen kann mit Blick auf Markus Söder
der kommt ja dahin und glaubt sozusagen
sich an die Spitze der Bewegung setzen
zu können und wird dann ausgepfiffen das
fand ich ja doch eigentlich eine
interessanten Moment und er macht
eigentlich den zweiten Fehler ja schon
zum zweiten also er macht den zweiten
Fehler hintereinander 2018 hat er das
auch schon gemacht ähnlich damals mit
der AFD in den Sound übernommen im
asylstreit und so er hat damals gesagt
das war meine politische Nahtoderfahrung
und jetzt geht er aber wieder sozusagen
zu einer Gruppe wo er glaubt da kann er
vielleicht Punkten und was gewinnen und
es funktioniert wieder nicht also
Opportunismus wird durchschaut ja das
ist ja vielleicht auch die gute
Nachrichten vor oder sie wollten gerade
ja die Frage ist ja worum geht's
eigentlich wirklich also vielleicht wenn
wir das einmal und das ist ja gerade
schon so ein bisschen in diesem
verhörsstyle äh in den den Menschen die
zu meiner Rechten hier jetzt ist nicht
politisch orientiert sondern einfach
hier jetzt logistisch orientiert haben
also
worum geht es eigentlich wirklich ne
kulturkampfpolitik Kampf und so weiter
also aus einem ganz naiven Verständnis
einer Neurowissenschaftlerin gefragt ja
wozu ist Politik denn eigentlich gut
eigentlich geht es doch darum unser
Zusammenleben so habe ich das verstanden
bitte korrigieren Sie mich ja wenn das
irgendwie anders ist unser Zusammenleben
zu organisieren oder besser zu
organisieren ja und dafür brauche ich
doch bitte keinen Kulturkampf und auch
keine ablenkungs weiß ich nicht was
Maschinerie wenn ich jetzt mal so ein
Begriff an der Stelle mit einbringen
möchte kann wie auch immer um irgendwie
Entscheidungen zu treffen sondern zu
sagen und das haben sie ja eben auch aus
meiner Sicht richtig wenn es wenn wir
diese Politik Definition uns darauf
eingehen können gesagt ja natürlich
gibt's da unterschiedliche Meinung bzw
Haltung ich hoffe dass es Haltung sind
und die basieren eben auf entsprechenden
Fakten und Untersuchungen und so weiter
und nicht ja ich habe da meine Meinung
und dann kann auch vortrefflich darüber
gestritten werden aber doch weil es um
diese Sache gehen sollte in diesem Fall
eben ein Ziel einzuhalten was ich die
Bundesregierung meines Wissens nach
einheitlich gesetzt Angst hat
Reduzierung von CO2 und anderen
klimaschädlichen Gasen und so weiter bis
da und dahin in den verschiedenen
Sektoren in diesem Fall jetzt Gebäude so
und dann können wir doch hingehen und
sagen als Gesellschaft mit den
verschiedenen Teilen darin Medien
Politik und wir sind ja jetzt auch Teil
der Medien gerade hier wie wollen wir
darüber reden damit wir irgendwie
Lösungen finden damit wir das gut machen
und diese ganze Diskussion die jetzt
gerade hier geführt wurde das finde ich
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich befremdlich weil
sie eigentlich das Gegenteil bei mir
erreicht wenn ich mich jetzt als
Bürgerin des Landes sehe und versuche zu
verstehen was da eventuell passiert weil
es genau das kreiert was ich eben gesagt
habe nämlich Unsicherheit ja also wenn
irgendwelche Worte wie Ideologie und
Atombombe ja die erstmal total
alarmmechanismus in mir auslösen ja also
jetzt Steinzeit hier in mäßig gedacht
mein Hirn eben in Alarmbereitschaft
versetzt wird ja ähm und nicht dazu
führen dass ich mich als Bürgerin
zurücklehnen kann und sagen okay das ist
ja eine Demokratie und die ist gewählt
und so weiter oder die Regierung das
gewählt in einer Demokratie und die
finden jetzt schon eine gute
Entscheidung genau das Gegenteil wird
von mir kreiert und ich glaube darüber
oder ich bin davon überzeugt dass ja
keine Glaubensfrage von überzeugt dass
wir darüber mehr sprechen sollten auch
hier und heute hoffentlich mal gucken
wie wir das hinkriegen aber insgesamt
sowohl medial als auch politisch und
nicht irgendwelche krankenkämpfe noch
aufmachen weil wir haben im wahrsten des
Wortes keine Zeit mehr vielleicht kommen
wir da gleich auch noch zu ja also die
Klimaziele sind da oder das Klima Limit
ist da wir am Stand heute noch sechs
Jahre ein Monat ich habe die Zahl extra
vor der Sendung noch mal nachgeguckt und
neun Tage wenn wir so weitermachen wie
bisher das Klima Budget also dieses
diesen Kuchen an CO2 die mir noch
ausstoßen können auszustoßen wenn wir
uns anders 1,5 Grad Limit wirklich
halten wie viel Zeit sechs Jahre ein
Monat 9 Tage stand heute das kann jemand
so genau sagen das ist sind Berechnung
das man kann das auf dem Karte Institut
nachgucken von ganz ganz vielen schlauen
Menschen die sich mit Klima und so
weiter beschäftigen und die dann gucken
okay wie viel CO2 ne ging in gigaton
gemessen haben wir noch und stand heute
wenn wir so machen wie bisher wir haben
im letzten Jahr einen weiteren Rekord
global gehabt mit 36,8 Gigatonnen CO2
weltweit die ausgestoßen wurden dann
haben wir noch diese sechs Jahre wie
gesagt einen Monat und neun Tage ich
muss es zugeben
deshalb wäre es doch umso wichtiger dass
wir jetzt vielleicht eine Lösung auf den
Tag genau zu sagen dann ist unser beide
vorbei 60 prozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit
okay nicht unwichtig in dem Zusammenhang
absolut gesagt also das ich hoffe das
ist okay
also sie sagen gerade irgendwie wir
sollten hier nicht so reden und wir
sollten hier nicht irgendwie komische
Wörter benutzen wobei er ist mich
tatsächlich sehr interessiert irgendwie
wenn jemand auf der Bühne steht und von
Heiz Ideologie und so weiter spricht
oder wenn ein bayerischer
Wirtschaftsminister sagt wir lassen uns
mal die Demokratie zurückholen das finde
ich sonst zwei unterschiedliche Dinge
als Kampfbegriff in der politischen
Auseinandersetzung oder ob man sagt wir
leben nicht in einer Demokratie ich
glaube der entscheidende Punkt ist
entscheidende Frage ist korrespondiert
mein Argument Kor fundiert meinen mein
Satz den ich sage auf so einer Bühne mit
einem realen politischen Punkt also der
Frage machen wir jetzt eine
Privilegierung von Wärmepumpen oder
machen wir auch noch andere heizformen
in das Gesetz rein darüber kann man dann
streiten Kulturkampf wird es dann wenn
es eigentlich gar keinen politischen
Punkt gibt sondern wenn eine quatschen
aufgemacht wird über Gendern über
Islamisierung des Abends wenn solche
Sachen plötzlich aufgeplustert werden ja
das sind Kulturkämpfe die von rechts und
von links geführt werden und die
brauchen wir nicht aber nach
Auseinandersetzung über die Frage ist es
eine Privilegierung für die Wärmepumpe
oder ist sie nicht das korrespondiert
hat mit einem echten Thema
also ich habe ja nichts gegen eine harte
politische Sprache ich selber Pflege
auch durchaus eine harte politische
Sprache in der Auseinandersetzung aber
es ist ja schon auffällig das mit so top
Häuser gearbeitet wird wie
erziehungsdikator also ich glaube
jeglicher Grundlage das irgendeine der
Parteien in der ampelregierung eine
Erziehungsdiktatur
sozusagen aufsetzen will und da passt
natürlich eine heizungsideologie man
kann natürlich sagen das Gesetz ist
schlecht weil es wie sie jetzt gesagt
haben eine bestimmte Heizart bevorzugt
und man müsste da offener machen da kann
das kann man auch gerne mit einer harten
Sprache machen aber man hört ja immer
wieder und deswegen ist es Teil dieses
Kulturkampf das ist ein Teil des
Kulturkampfes weil ich glaube bestimmte
politische Kräfte in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland sehen ganz genau dass wir
jetzt in dieser Phase sind wo es eine
ökologische eine ökonomische
Transformation geben muss und wenn die
eingeleitet wird ist der Zug natürlich
abgefahren für bestimmte Klientel die
sie gerne wählen und die versuchen Sie
jetzt unter sämtlichen Aspekten zu
mobilisieren wie ist das wenn die Grünen
sagen Schuldenbremse ist FDP Ideologie
Schuldenbremsen Ideologie sparfetisch
von Christian Lindner ist das
Kulturkampf und ist das schädlich für
die politische Kultur oder ist das
normales politisch jeden Tag deswegen
habe ich extra einen größeren
zusammenhalten
Ideologie der vorher noch in dem
Zusammenhang von der Erziehungsdiktatur
gesprochen hat also das passt dann schon
zusammen ich habe nichts dagegen wenn
man sagt das ist ein Fetisch das ist
eine Ideologie das ist alles okay das
ist alles sozusagen in bestimmten
auseinander ich finde den schaefflersatz
auch bescheuert aber geschenkt ja na ja
er macht er macht Angst aber er fügt
sich in dieses größere narrativ ein das
über Angst Wählerschicht so sozusagen
mobilisiert werden sollen wir über die
auseinandersetzen
mobilisieren ich glaube das ist die
Frage machen Auseinandersetzung kann ich
auch mal gerne das Breitschwert benutzen
genau
wobei ich ist schon interessant finde
auch in Ihrem Sinne heute mal deswegen
will ich die Frage gerne an Zeit medical
weitergeben meine wir auch als Medien
selbstkritik ist ja nicht so unsere
Kernkompetenz da sind wir nicht so
richtig gut drin aber vielleicht kommt
das heute ja mal versuchen zu
Abwechslung
wir springen doch genau auf sowas an und
Herr Scheffler der sagt Atombombe
weiß das doch auch ganz genau das ist
doch die Überschrift die in ihrem Sinne
dazu führt jedes negative Wort zwei
Prozent mehr das ist nicht mein Sinn ne
sondern das ist das ist auch das
Studienergebnisse weil das jetzt so
klingt als ob ich mir das irgendwie im
Stillen kämmern
sie sagen jedes negative Wort in einer
Überschrift ist auch gut untersucht 14
wie viel mehr 3% jedes negative Wort
jedes einzelne das heißt zwei Wörter für
uns zu 5 % mehr Klicks oder wie also es
ist keine lineare Funktion aber es geht
in die Richtung genau richtig das heißt
Hammer Atombombe in Verbindung das
genau so
ich und gehe ich gehe ich absolut mit
den Punkt ich meine wir leben von
solchen Überschriften das muss man schon
sagen ja also wir befinden uns ja in
einem Kampf um Aufmerksamkeit ja in
einem ganz schönen harten
Konkurrenzkampf das ist ja auch nicht
mehr so ganz wie in 80er 90er Jahren wo
es ein paar Zeitungen und zwei drei
Magazine gehabt sondern das hat sich
alles ausgefächert die Medienlandschaft
und das sind natürlich Verlage sind
enorm unter Druck definitiv
das heißt es gibt natürlich eine Neigung
zur zur überstützung zur Dramatisierung
auch zur sozusagen aggressionsbericht
Erstattung also der der Thesen starken
Berichterstattung natürlich für trotzdem
sagen es ist eine Illusion zu glauben
dass das früher nie der Fall war also
ähm der Spiegel beispielsweise ja wir
haben darüber ganz viel diskutiert
wenn man sich da mal wenn man da mal ein
paar Blätter durchblätter hat aus dem
60er 70er 80er Jahren also das war auch
die reine Apokalypse ehrlich gesagt ja
und wie Politik da betrieben wurde ja
reine machtpolitische
Auseinandersetzungen und so ja die
Konzentration auf Machtkämpfe aufs
negative ja auf Rücktritte und Stürze
und so also die ich würde fast sagen die
Intonierung hat sich da gar nicht so
wahnsinnig verändert es ist vor allem
doch die Geschwindigkeit die
Geschwindigkeit hat sich verändert und
das digitale ja es geht sozusagen
intravenös rein ja wenn man das auf dem
Handy ja wenn man es auf dem Handy
sozusagen man konsumiert ja heutzutage
Medien weitgehend auf dem auf dem Handy
jedenfalls so in unserer Generation und
das ich glaube also sie sind die
Neurowissenschaftlerin aber ich glaube
das macht was mit einem ja